let's bring in Sentinel action fund
president Jessica Anderson and former
Texas congresswoman Myra Flores uh
welcome to you both two of the big
topics last night going forward was the
Border abortion I want to like take a
look at this quote if I can it says here
and put this up on the screen and Lead
Me it says uh do you as a res this is
Chicago you can see this right here the
total number by the way is 11 Terror
attacks total Terror watch lless people
before Biden took office and the three
or four years before that and since he's
taken office the number is
282 Myra I mean it's it's really a
stunning dichotomy of numbers pre and
post
Biden I'm a border patrol wife and I
deal with the southern border situation
every single day we don't have just a
humanitarian crisis we have a national
security crisis and my condolences to
the family that lost their loved ones in
this tragic accident that could have
been prevented but the Biden
Administration refus refuses to enforce
the immigration laws refuses to secure
the border and these tragic accidents
will continue to happen unless the Biden
Administration secures the Border yeah
and the crowds that flooding Chicago by
the way a city council meeting here's
Alderman Anthony Nano asking the crowd a
question about all these illegal
migrants that have come in
watch do you as a resident of the city
of Chicago believe that we should remain
a sanctuary City it's a simple question
[Applause]
[Music]
I mean they're Fed Up from coast to
coast
Jessica wow I mean look at this the
American people are right right to be
livid about the situation at the border
it's a humanitarian crisis it's one of
National Security but it's also one that
Biden could quickly fix let's remember
he has tools at his disposal to secure
the border and the house has already
written negotiated and passed hr2 which
is a very strong and comprehensive
border and Security package that is
sitting in the United State Senate so
Senate Democrats need to join House
Republicans and put this bill on the
president's desk secure I wonder if I
wonder if I can get 15 seconds from each
of you abortion was a big topic last
night is there for the Republicans is
there a solution Myra 15
seconds absolutely it's time that the
Republican party uh talks about the
Democrat Party stand the Democrat Party
supports abortion up to 9 months with no
restrictions they have no respect for
human life I stand with women who are
victims of abuse of rape and life of the
mother but the Democrat Party is using
them to push their radical agenda yeah
Jessica 10
seconds the Republican party needs to
embrace not just a culture of life but
the right to life seeing what happened
in Ohio the seventh state now post dos
to enshrine abor in our constitution is
wrong and it's out of step with our
fundamental principle to support the
American right to life that's where we
thank you both coming hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling annalysis
you will not get it anywhere
else